what is your standard for every movie
that you make I have a high standard I
mean
I I feel like any film I'm going to make
I don't want anyone to question what the
budget was you know I I I think you have
to go in I think you have to know your
limitations and make sure that people
are watching the scene and they're like
oh this is good if you know for a
lowbudget movie or for an indie
movie I try to make sure the production
value is as high as a big studio
production I just think that's and if
you you you can't overextend yourself I
think that's what a lot of firsttime
filmmakers that's the mistake they make
is they try to make a big movie on a
small budget and you can see all the
holes in it you you can't you can't
allow yourself to be in that situation
because an audience will tune out if you
can tell a lowbudget
story and make a good movie should you
be doing car chases and and big
shootouts if you can't afford to do it
you shouldn't do it you should write a
different story I think that's a big
part of
like you know the James Cameron method
of of making a movie like you you you're
you're always striving to do the best
you can you're going Beyond you know
you're when you're if you shoot for the
stars and you're not happy with it but
you've shot so far that for the audience
they they won't see the difference
they'll be happy with it so then to to
really question should this just be a
one uh location shot I mean film excuse
me so you're not overextending yourself
with um dramatic car chase as you say
yeah I mean well that's exactly what we
did for last shift I mean we didn't we
didn't have the budget to to do that
kind of stuff so we were like well how
do we make how do we basically stay in
this one location but make a really
entertaining movie that people aren't
questioning oh this feels low budget or
this this you know is boring I think
that's the the first part of like
knowing your target range for money what
what your budget size you're aiming for
how much can you raise how much can you
get how much are the investors putting
into it and then cater your film around
that in a way even if you have a written
script already don't just go into
production with it just make sure you're
you're not overextending yourself on the
page were you tempted to do that at all
for the last shift like oh maybe we
could squeeze in a a a street scene or
something that you aside from you know
some of the beginning last shift I
wasn't
because I had done dread was my first
feature and it had a you know had a
sizable
budget and I learned a lot from that
movie because you know was like aund
12 page
script and
the the process of making that movie you
know you're getting everything on the
page I learned that the way I wrote was
very dense I I fit a lot of details on a
page and when you're shooting that it
makes it much longer you're getting all
these little character moments or you're
getting close-ups on things and I ended
up cutting like 45 minutes out of that
movie because it was too long now in in
your mind you're like 45 minutes that's
days and days of work that you could
have spent somewhere else you could have
spent that money on something else you
know that's just wasted money it's not
ending up on the screen so when we did
last shift we shot a 69 page
screenplay most people would shoot a
90minut move 90 page screenplay and even
when we showed it to some people like
some investor friends
they were like it's only 69 Pages it's
like yeah I know trust me that's exactly
the page it needed to be and it was it
ended up being like 90 minutes on the
nose I couldn't cut a single I didn't
cut anything out of that movie I used
every frame we
shot um because we couldn't the movie
would have been too
short
so that we were very disciplined on that
on that movie how do you challenge
yourself with each new product
project I spend a lot of
time on performances I think I think the
two places I try to extend myself on are
are again working with actors I love
working with actors it's a reason why I
like to direct and I think uh when I
watch a movie I'm always gauging My
Success on the performance of the actor
and did they get to where they need to
go are they giving a convincing
performance are they comfortable are
they pushing themselves as an actor so
when I'm in the editing process I'm
looking at all that and then the other
ways is with camera I
think because I'm so performance-based I
have to be very mindful of what am I
doing with the camera is it interesting
enough you how are we challenging
ourselves with the Angles and the you
know can you shoot this I like it when
you're
you're I'm not very rigid when I when I
make a movie I'm very loose I don't I
don't storyboard a lot I'll storyboard
maybe the scares some of the big actions
pieces St like that but I kind of like
to let the actors dictate how we shoot a
movie what what are they doing in the
blocking and then and then shoot around
it and you know you have to plan for
certain shots with equipment and you
know you want to get those shots but for
a lot of it I like it to just come out
of the
moment and sometimes when you're
watching the actors you have ideas about
like why don't we shoot this with one
take you know why don't we do this whole
scene in a
Wier and let the camera move around them
and and sometimes you can save time that
way you spend time getting it right but
once you get it right you end up saving
a lot on on not covering it in other
ways
so that's always for me it's like I like
to be in the moment and challenge s in
the moment and always
be kind of present to pick up on the
special things that happen in a movie
and not be so rigid so that's always
part of that pushing myself is just
constantly being in the moment with the
actors and does part of not being rigid
mean letting an actor come up with their
own dialogue if they say a line slightly
off oh for sure works okay I I always
tell actors like do not worry about the
dialogue on the the page you know say it
in your own words and and also I like
to I I like to play with the actors you
know and I'll tell them you know are you
comfortable with improv like are
you because I think you'll often get the
most genuine performances if you tell
one actor to do something completely
different and then you get the reaction
from the person on camera so they're
never quite sure and also that creates
an err of like well I have to be on my
toes in a sense like be ready to play um
and and allow yourself to be surprised
by things but yeah dialogue to me
whenever I tell an actor that's
auditioning I'm like forget the dialogue
like do you know the intent of the scene
then just say it in your own words and
and you know certainly when you're
shooting you have to be mindful of plot
but you don't have to do that on every
take you know you can all allow actors
to play on different takes and also I
like to like go beyond the scene not
call cut when they're expecting you to
call cut and you kind of just let let it
keep going and see what will
happen so that's all all kind of about
being in the moment there how do you
keep up with
technology yeah I mean I'm not the best
at keeping up with technology I can be
honest about that like I and because I
don't shoot a lot
myself it's something I have to be more
mindful of I I think you know when I'm
you know it's I'm very much the kind of
filmmaker that
is I like to give my
departments their space in the sense
that I want them to all perform at their
best I don't want to micromanage things
so especially with my you know it's
about being with your anytime I'm
approaching a new project it's getting
early on in prep with your DP and and
almost learning the technology then well
what's at our disposal what would I like
to do with this movie this is to me I'm
just thinking like as a creative in the
sense of this is what I want this is
what I'd like to do and I let the
experts in their field tell me the best
way to achieve it so for me technology
is final draft and making sure my
updates up to date you know and Premiere
making sure you know the editing
software is up to date and and but
camera it's really about me speaking
with the DP and getting on the same page
with
them